[Música]
albert einstein decía la locura es hacer
lo mismo una y otra vez esperando
obtener resultados diferentes si quieres
tener resultados diferentes tienes que
hacer cosas diferentes esa frase me
encanta saben por qué porque vivimos en
un mundo que se está actualizando
constantemente día con día 24/7 lo que
provoca que lo que funcionaba en el
pasado ahora en la actualidad está
quedando totalmente obsoleto y lo mismo
sucede con nosotros si nosotros no nos
reinventamos si nosotros no nos
actualizamos probablemente nos quedemos
obsoletos
yo soy estudiante ingeniera de software
por lo tanto desarrollo tecnología la
tecnología es increíble la tecnología
nos va ayudar y probablemente la
tecnología va a salvar al planeta pero
sabe que va a suceder durante ese
proceso muchos empleos muchas industrias
van a desaparecer muchas de las
habilidades que hoy son muy valiosas en
un futuro no muy lejano van a perder su
valor porque porque ahorita se encuentra
en nuestra realidad tendencias que están
arrasando con todo lo que se pone en su
camino
y esas tendencias son la automatización
internet de las cosas inteligencia
artificial blogging etcétera y en mi
experiencia esta es una carrera de
tecnología en la que participan
estudiantes de todo el mundo empresas de
todo el mundo por crear
un objetivo en común que es cambiar al
mundo poner uso de la tecnología como
dato curioso usualmente la tecnología
que usamos al día de hoy es tecnología
que se desarrolla así como es años y
probablemente la tecnología que tengamos
a nuestro acceso dentro de 10 años es
tecnología que se desarrolló el día de
hoy bien vivimos en un sistema
capitalista que exige cada vez personas
más competitivas más preparadas con más
habilidades que las hagan únicas para
que no las pueda reemplazar un robot yo
creo que el mayor ejemplo de esto son
los coches que antes eran caballos henry
ford decía que se le hubiera preguntado
a las personas que querían le hubieran
dicho que caballos más rápidos en fin
hemos visto cambios radicales en la
agroindustria en la construcción en la
industria espacial etcétera pero saben
donde no hemos visto cambios radicales
en la educación en la escuela en la
universidad
cuántos ingenieros cuántos doctores
cuántos contadores nos salen al año de
las universidades parece máquina de
churros sacando profesionistas un
función y a todos les enseñan lo mismo
los conocimientos de la escuela no te
hacen especial memorizar y escupir lo
será un examen menos y aquí la pregunta
es que te va a diferenciar porque tú y
no otro de las millones de personas que
estudian lo mismo que tú
de ahí me paso a un concepto super
importante que es la heurística de la
disponibilidad en qué consiste la
heurística de la disponibilidad la
heurística de la disponibilidad consiste
en que solamente lo que tiene disponible
en la cabeza de información es para ti
la realidad por eso es que la realidad
es muy subjetiva porque es importante
esto miren yo lo veo así el mundo se va
a dividir en dos los que se quedaron
conformistas solamente con lo que les
dieron en la escuela qué es lo que
desean a todo el mundo los que tuvieron
hambre de ir por más por más
conocimientos los que tuvieron
curiosidad y fueron autodidactas los que
tienen comprender el funcionamiento del
mundo y por qué hacemos lo que hacemos
para esto no necesitas ir a la mejor
universidad del mundo para obtener la
mejor información saben dónde está la
mejor información esta cosita que muchos
utilizan para verme mes nosotros la
utilizamos para entrar a foros
internacionales tomar cursos estar en
contacto con personas de todo el mundo
miren les va a pasar un tipo usualmente
yo me meto a foros internacionales
voy al apartado de expertos y busco a
esas personas en cualquier red social y
les mando mensaje es increíble porque
estoy en contacto con ellos pues con
personas de todas partes del mundo
lo importante esto es el intercambio de
perspectivas imagínate que hablas con
personas que son de áfrica con personas
que son de europa con personas que son
de américa entonces empiezas a agarrar
ideas de uno ideas de otro ideas de otro
y al final terminas aprendiendo y
creciendo aprendiendo creciendo
aprendiendo y creciendo hasta que llega
un punto donde sales innovando algo algo
nuevo haciendo una disrupción total
así es como se crea la innovación nada
se crea de la nada imagínate que te
dicen a ver imagina un color que nunca
has visto en tu vida no se puede la
materia no se crea la materia no se crea
ni se destruye solamente se transforma
por ejemplo este las personas que
inventaron internet no dijeron hoy vamos
a inventar una red invisible que conecta
a todo el mundo para que tengan acceso a
la información así no pasa si no es así
no funciona todo se crea con base en
cosas ya existentes por ejemplo la
biomimética que la biométrica es tomar a
la naturaleza como inspiración para
crear innovaciones tecnológicas y
ejemplos hay muchísimos por ejemplo los
sistemas de ventilación modernos en la
construcción que se inspiraron en el
comportamiento de las abejas en sus
panales etcétera hay muchísimos procesos
por eso es muy importante la heurística
de la disponibilidad porque mira
si tú le metes muy poquita información a
tu cabeza vas a tener una interpretación
de la realidad muy corta muy limitada en
cambio simplemente es información
aprendizajes conocimientos y demás vas a
poder comprender la realidad de una
forma más amplia vas a empezar a
conectar puntos y quién sabe qué es
algún día termines nadando un proyecto
al espacio un día de estos pero ojo
desde mi punto de vista no es sólo meter
la información y ya está así no funciona
estamos en una época en la que nunca
habíamos tenido acceso a tanta
información y eso es un problema porque
hay mucha información que no te sirve
y nosotros tenemos que ir en búsqueda de
esa información que es solo para
nosotros pero para poder encontrarla
tenemos que hacernos las siguientes
preguntas porque quiero aprender esto
para que lo voy a aprender cómo lo voy a
aprender ya sea cursos libros audio
etcétera y esto es muy importante de
quién lo voy a aprender porque tienes
que irte con el mejor con el más grande
recuerda que tienes que ser muy
estratégico y muy cuidadoso por las
cosas que le metes a tu cabeza porque
eso depende de tu vida y no te lo tomes
a la ligera no es un chiste estoy
hablando muy en serio muy en serio
amigos yo quiero invitarlos a que
terminando esta charla tomen un libro
tomen un curso lean un artículo los
cambios reales radicales no se hacen de
la noche a la mañana muchos se proponen
leer un libro completo pero yo les
propongo que en una hoja luego lean dos
luego tres y al final van a terminar
leyendo todo el libro la mejor inversión
del mundo no es en bienes raíces más en
acciones ni tampoco de cripto minas
la mejor inversión del mundo es invertir
en uno mismo tú eres el mayor activo que
tienes si tú te encargas de llenar tu
cabeza tu cabeza se va a encargar de
llenar tus bolsillos
esta experiencia es más personal desde
que yo me ate entre en el conocimiento
esas ganas de aprender más mi vida
cambió drásticamente se me abrieron
nuevas oportunidades esos sueños que
parecían lejanos o muy difíciles de
alcanzar se empezaron a volver una
realidad también llegaron personas
increíbles a mi vida que me impulsaron
bastante lo curioso de esto es que a mí
no me gustaba no me gustaba leer no me
gustaba aprender lo aborrecía pero era
consciente de que si quería resultados
diferentes tenía que hacer cosas
diferentes entonces comencé a adentrarme
descubrí cosas nuevas cosas que me
llaman la atención descubrir lo que me
apasionaba porque antes no sabía que era
lo que me apasionaba descubrí en que era
bueno y al final y al final todo esto lo
terminé convirtiendo en un estilo de
vida propio y estoy fascinado porque ha
sido lo mejor que me ha pasado en la
vida
cuando te adentras en el aprendizaje te
das cuenta de que hay formas de aprender
más en menos tiempo de que puedes
potencializar tus sentidos para que los
tengas a tu disposición que hay atajos
en la vida que te pueden ahorrar mucho
tiempo y desgaste pero estas
revelaciones no están al acceso de todo
el mundo solamente están disponibles
para aquellas personas que están
dispuestas a adentrarse a este mundo el
aprendizaje infinito
todos estos conocimientos que fue
adquiriendo en mi trayecto de vida me
permitieron realizar proyectos que
fueron destacando a nivel nacional e
internacional por ejemplo envió un
proyecto al espacio desarrolló un
dispositivo que me permite alertar a los
atletas antes de que sufran una lesión
represente a méxico en la onu y otros
proyectos
este pero si algo les puedo decir es que
si algo es realmente importante deberían
intentarlo
incluso si el resultado final es fracaso
si quieres tener resultados
extraordinarios tienes que hacer
acciones extraordinarias muchísimas
gracias
[Música]